all right I'm gonna start the voyage and
then I'm gonna go have a PPE ok smack
that BP around please don't I why would
we die immediately we're good I don't
know what I want to eat I have to get
some food for myself if you could your
food to you too
come on man don't don't be like that
[ __ ] oh I know it is like this you know
me better than that
look at us
I'm a lady didn't realize this one oh
I'm in the game which one am I think
you're the lady they changed my
appearance to I don't think I was a
goateed lady last oh hey how are you
it's too late those'll a customization
was in the earlier one I'm Sondra all
right I called dibs on
some mills what is shooting load I can
give you commands you have by approval
you putrid dig power to the engines
power to shields yes please and power to
gun yes please what a space oh space is
boost oh [ __ ]
we have boost now guys I can't see
outside so tell me when to shoot outside
use queue to look outside oh I forgot we
could all do that in any time that's
really handy well how do I know what
button to press to shoot space I believe
a shoot you turn it with the west and in
you spacerino to shoot arena cool this
game was really cool yeah I remember the
first time I played this game I was like
oh [ __ ] this space to shoot this space
to shoot yeah it's space to shoot
captain wait damn oh oh oh that seems
like a meat thing to do in my way dude
man the Sharks way okay I'm trying to
like loading the kind of gun you're
gonna have to lower yourself I'm working
on the things please wait idle a bullet
which I can't
ah the guy said you download yourself
Wade I loaded it for you now I'm gonna
load no I just load it for you oh god
are you not listening to me see you
asked how would we stuck holding a
Gundam you're the gunner not you thank
you first try I did it
where's this other leak where's the leak
mark party fixing the leaks there it is
shut the [ __ ] up hey hey you
Oh apparently I used up a bunch of my
boosts whoopsies all right doesn't have
to be loaded and one does well shoot
shoot wait [ __ ] shoot things I'm
trying I was in the wrong gun at the aim
one one has to be loaded one dozen I
there are multiple guns in this game
literally 30 seconds ago I was like wait
why are you cheating it was that was
busy ordering myself food food except
hungry
ah right that's a good excuse three
sharks they shooting them get the other
gun out and shoot them
Oh God oh they're really high they're
really but they're really beefing up the
antigravity might help he need my help
but you're you are close [ __ ] aim
towards the shark please you [ __ ]
aimed at the ground you're gonna wait
you've played this before you have you
played this okay can we turn the engines
off and just [ __ ] regroup for a second
yes hang on I'm turning the engines off
I'm giving us more shield okay yeah
shield shield this [ __ ] up let me fix
it we're drowning I got it I got it how
do we get the how do we get the water
out it'll go out naturally if you patch
up all the holes wait I think you might
be drowning oh god oh god I I need my
water levels to go to we I know I know
way you sure do don't you yeah sure dude
guys I'm gonna die we're gonna kill them
think I got all the things I think I got
all the things alright cool wait do you
want to drive the thing and I'll shoot
the shape and I know but you shooting
was so frustrating I did my best was
this door open here we go there we go
maybe just maybe the problem wasn't me
no the problem was exclusively you I'm
100% sure certain that the problem was
you shark
I I'm gunning I'm gunning [ __ ] you Wade
I'm gonna rest in bed for just a second
I've got a wicked splitting headache you
guys arguing all the time
whoa his family apart implied
something wrong Wade you have done many
things wrong oh that's fine no go into
the cave go into the game we want that
cave of mysteries hermit hovel suck what
is that what is this what we do what is
this what is this I don't know did you
have multiple guns or something what
does this do
I don't know that's dope though I think
it's I assume it it kills things
probably but I can't repair with it well
no you do have two gun slots how do you
switch your gun slots cuz it says in the
in if you had tab it says wrench and
none like we should have a secondary
guns I've got the Eldridge staff and
nothing so how do i okay well one of you
can take it if you want but I guess if
I'm not sparing I should have it no I'm
gonna look at that control there's no
option oh you guys control way do you
have no ground to stand on air what the
[ __ ] whoa what the [ __ ] oh my god whoa
what the [ __ ] what was that I don't know
what that was you need a backpack
do that so we need backpacks all right
why didn't we bring those into our
submarine so someone else take it I'm
gonna be repairing someone else naked
who's like on guns or something who can
help kill I think Wade should take it
because I'm gonna be the one who's
helping you repair if [ __ ] goes I should
be repairing if someone else's on guns
or dry oh I'm piloting though you're
piloting for some right I think we got
everything from this this area
what's a weapon yeah but I think it also
summoned that weird demon thing so
there's like a chance thing or mark mark
yes don't walk like that's terrifying oh
it's wrong yeah you afraid the
flexibility to show you a leg Etan the
legs of which you've never seen
oh I like the way my Gooch scrapes on
the floor meet me in the corner I'm
ready okay goodbye
wait oh [ __ ] we have a limited number of
torpedoes yes Wade I'm ready for you
where'd you go man [ __ ] me there we go
[Music]
let's go wait wait to thing what do you
mean you're not there I mean I wasn't
there this is a tiny ship Wade it takes
like two seconds to go from where you
were to where you wait Bob I'm gonna
test out I'm gonna give all power to the
guns does your machine-gun get any more
powerful is that faster that's faster
right that's a little yeah I take away
one power fire now faster with more
power Oh more shark okay more power
Oh God Nemo not like this okay
fixing leak okay Bobby might be close to
drowning I'm fixing it up right now as
much as I can
got it alright good oh yeah it'sit's
good let's get that mark go for it you
get it mark I got it don't
I'm good I'm good this is my favorite
thing to do is my favorite what that
need what you owe us what's there - made
it buddy is my favorite I mean it's my
favorite I favor it I love it I tried to
chill for a second to repair stuff yeah
shake we're good I'm [ __ ] get it off I
am about to die you fix that up I'm
going to just sleep big enough oh oh I'm
crowning
I've got seasickness alright I gotta go
do the thing alright
torpedoes you just go I'm fine I'm good
I'm good I'm gonna you don't look so
good I'm seasick but I'm good alright
whatever here I just you're full of
torpedoes use it if you need it okay all
right now guys go chill first I go like
in bed for a second or something inside
oh Jesus Christ
it's just that way for ya I keep trying
go up I guess if you can yeah evasive
maneuvers or something just call me
shark sniper babe okay shark sniper bad
in here today how many shots from that
gun does it take to kill one of those
things yeah I wasn't I was oh babe oh no
boy run away run left front left that
gets me good shot okay go under repair
I'm good I'm good boss how do i how do
you unsee sick I look terrible I'm a
look I'm gonna take care of you baby
soft sweet baby baby no I was just
helping you okay okay helping you meant
it was just my sickness rubbing off on
me where's the shark down I moved away
from it all right I might if i smart
like a smart you did
oh good Bab now that's a snack or find
out about going on oh let me give you a
real oh that's good moves all right
you're one you're oh you just gave me
seasickness I think I shat on the floor
all over the Floyd wait we need to go
deeper Oh sick we literally have been at
the same depth for like this whole time
go deeper I'm ready to fight I'm healed
up to 14 torpedoes yeah I'm gonna stop
using them for a minute
oh I am very barfy my boils are covering
my mustache I don't think that's right
what is that sound my face Bob the gun
it's our vision so badly target about
hang on okay I hear that where's that oh
do it um Magnum captain we're going deep
no oh god no it's parked out as you can
I feel like my my perspective is broken
oh [ __ ] switch to torpedoes here for a
second and just give us a little boost
away from me okay get the K boss in the
cab
oh good good job boss good job when did
we decide that ba or Wade was gonna be
boss I don't know it's just natural
pecking order you guys don't look so
good horrible horrible thing
you talking about orange bubbles coming
your nose where's the [ __ ] is your nose
yeah whatever man there it's fine Oh God
[ __ ] off away from you all know what
that's God no I'm going outside [ __ ]
this
all right I don't see comes out of my
helmet i shat on the floor oh god no
you've gotta go you've got your [ __ ] ha
ha ha ha I got a backpack way to run
ahead and get all the supplies Bob
that's what I do
fuckos well there's a name thing chip
weapon person help it doesn't have a
name no behind him there's like a crab
with a name wage shoot I am shooting
shoot more get them oh my one shot Wow
oh there he is down here wait wait wait
I want to go to bed you've used you hose
you've used the wand too much that's
from the wand oh boy oh dear thank you
guys give me any warning labels mark
said that out loud in English yeah I
definitely did it clearly did that guy's
still alive ow ow ow ow ow ow ow look I
can't move again well yeah oh gee Oh
more coming back more dude more do that
full full [ __ ] speed combat role on
my way over here where you [ __ ] at
we're over here oh okay so hey how do I
get that super dope chest I'm
or you get nothing I'm getting it no
shut down ere I shat everywhere so it's
probably me
oh who just left me got the dope oh
forgot it was on me you couid you you
had an my lord you have a weapon man god
damn I know and I want more in any way
look at how [ __ ] fast I am
dude the combat role is the way to go I
[Laughter]
wasn't orange but you know whatever
whatever we're all like together in this
I suppose susceptible to illness or
something I don't know starfish carcass
near engine power engaged I'm gonna give
us two handbag actually no I'm gonna
give us a double gun just because it
seems like shooting him is more
important ahead at this point he's
[ __ ] even the bullets man go away nice
work
gunner bob is on this [ __ ] Oh go inside
oh okay there was a little squid [ __ ] I
figure yeah I think I was about to
destroy us guys
wait mark turn can you turn gun power on
for a second yeah hang on why what do
you need I think if you leave a torpedo
loaded oh wait we can't into what don't
do that don't do that I think you lose
torpedos that are loaded when you when
you deep our really yeah we were at 11
now we're at 10 torpedoes and the one
that was oh don't don't shoot him he
seems friendly hello hey
that's must be readable yeah it's
English can't you read that yeah it's so
small I can't [ __ ] in front of the new
guy oh god sorry sorry sorry sorry
Judas Wacken no I worked the poop who
they're merchants the gold means
something we need it they're gone rivet
gun I am I have five fifty four fifty
four oh you have gold if we if we kill
these guys till we get gold I think we
just don't get anything if we do that oh
[ __ ] we got to come back so close can we
you [ __ ] douche bag wait okay guys I
just want to say shut up you ruined
everything
you ruined it well you just want to say
I'll take the blame for that one
okay take the blame for that one
Wow geez man golly now did you shoot
them intentionally that's what I want to
know yeah he shot them intentionally
[ __ ] let's do this game but now that
we're good good just the best so give me
the weapon in the future I think the
staff of killing merpeople what that's
not what it does shoot them no no that
was we could have all made that happen
no that's ten
was talking to me it was called the
staff of killing more people it told me
I had to pull the trigger sometimes I
dream about smacking you right in your
face geez I don't you are bad at
streaming you eat after stream oh here
I'll just kick you out of the room and
just market oh good great it's gonna be
great voyage let's set off
I'm excited are you excited we can keep
this together we can be strong together
we can be strong this time yes this is
the bigger ship were you intentionally
getting the bigger ship this isn't the
bigger ship this is one we were just son
no no it's not yes this is not how the
pilot's seat was organized man telling
you oh this is this is a different ship
this is a big boy we got this Oh
oh yeah okay so we're gonna do this so
in this game it's probably fun are there
two guns they're hard Oh whoo guns there
are no shields don't worry
[ __ ] all right so mark you know you and
I have to trade off gunning and fixing
maybe yes okay your god I picked the
cravette that's my bad no no this will
be good it'll be good it'd be good how
do i how do I switch guns how do I
switch guns a and D back and forth right
right okay that's that's gonna take some
getting used to so generally you want to
aim you want to aim left and I'll aim
right mark and will be responsible for
like 180 you got it man you got it just
gonna shoot wherever mark is shooting if
I can't see what's happening I don't
know I'm just shooting in general the
only bad guys I saw are currently above
us into the heights shooting down is
probably a safe bet
all right shooting down it is
I wish that help the tooltips what is
that I don't know I don't know oh that's
always bad that thing that thinks bad
that's bad news yeah what is this blast
them blast
no that's a grabby bed that's a bad
crabby I'm trying I'm trying
alright never bad grab Oh God we're not
going this way oh that's our feeling
okay kill him
oh boy oh God are we leaking let me
check
we are I'm taking care of Malik on my
side there's some weird things leaks
leak okay that's a leak okay oh boy I
wish we had the other vehicle I'm dead
Tim to scrum the terrible is guarding my
corpse I'm dead okay wait are you alive
I am with someone's ghost oh god here
comes skittles wait you have one health
oh okay enemies no no what the [ __ ] that
escalated quickly yeah that was weird
one little shark oh the whole planets
after us now but it's fine you know why
it's fine because we are together as
friends we are together we are working
together I don't think so we are working
together also I forgot there's an EMP we
probably should have fired the ANP no
[ __ ] what does that do
I think it like disables everything
around
it blows all the power so that you can
sound on the survive alright I actually
just took Molly sandwich oh you like
spicy things it's bad oh it hurts what
did she get that was spicy spicy chicken
you're choking on a spicy you big baby
[ __ ] it's not expecting it you know it
sounds like you're dying
alright big tough point is that invite
they're both I'm invited I'm going and
this time we're gonna get it good we're
gonna feel great the right ship two to
three people we got that's the one we
guess what tries a tiny one oh yes yes
yes
yes I do I didn't even know that let's
do it yeah the tiny one the barrel mark
you've been doing power the whole time
you don't mean I'll do it
what but I just said all right you know
what did fine
I like this ship the ship's got good
layout I like this yeah I could I can I
can live with this yeah okay I'll pile
it I don't remember him I'll stand down
out of here okay go shoot you I don't
want you shooting the gun I'll do
everything you just stand there in the
pics holes come on time traveler meand
I don't know what who the [ __ ] are you
wha are you yeah there is what the [ __ ]
oh no is the game public who the [ __ ] is
this I think we have a Rando with us
okay whatever it's fine all right you
ready mark yeah I'm ready let's do this
well this is a lovely ship why haven't
we been doing this one this delightful
as it says it's for two people hey I
don't care it seems to be good good work
oh you're you run out of boosts mark I
don't know how you recharged that it you
have kind of a lot but like it doesn't
seem to like regenerate or anything oh
the Rando gave me a torpedo you didn't
know there was a boost no wait I don't
know I just feel like killing a
what's the boost button face it says it
real big on the screen when you're
piloting oh like one twentieth of the
screen it says space oh there's a shark
here work good work there are two sharks
here that's a problem no you keep them
on one side it takes it forever to turn
this fly right okay oh God hang on
evasive maneuvers there we go there we
go there yeah okay okay okay I hear the
sloshing sounds of water yeah we fixed
the 132 health up there's one we're fine
oh good starfish starfish starfish I got
them that's a lot of meat yeah that's a
lot of meat for a small starfish rate of
repair no repairs need to baby have
fought them off nicely
oh that's not it
thanks to excellent work and lot about
just our powerful weapons he gave me
more power to weapons what guys this
friend Oh mr. dream he's good he's good
he's good that one he knows what I do
like I trained him myself
wait would you shut the [ __ ] up and eat
you're not spicy sandwich nicely done
good work team okay van Gogh bag I'm
just gonna serve her meat wait until
he's done eating Little Nemo over there
no there's a very bad hose
Oh what the [ __ ] whack his arm back his
arm walk his arm apparently ha what the
[ __ ] why he grabbed me I'm sleeping the
soy sleeping sweeping it away
get away I'm sleeping did you just let
him grab you
no I was trying to jump into his
open-armed dude I've got this so ow oh
let's watch market divers joy landlubber
dude sick burn
dude that guy got us so how did he know
that was gonna happen
oh no maybe by the look of the cave this
this one this time we got this I like
that ship that's a good ship but I don't
think I'm best for piloting I think
someone best on repair I feel good on
repair oh okay whoa we can buy new ships
there's an S padam for 25000 gold [ __ ]
it's got a real do I have not enough we
don't know what I have you don't have
enough you don't know me you don't know
we have gotten nothing no unlocks no
relics no nothing we got it we got to
accomplish it this time we'll do it this
time if it's if it's bad homes in a
Cawood bad news in a cave we'll just
boogie on out of there just power up and
get the [ __ ] out exactly there's no
reason we need to stay into death we can
live outside of the death I'm asking Amy
if she can order some Wendy's because
Wade you made me hungry for it oh dude
food is so foodie food is so so Moody
yeah Bradford you like food you've done
food before try this food thing you put
it in your mouth I know it sounds weird
you're putting your mouth you smash it
with your bones in your mouth oh you
shove it inside you it's great and that
it's how swallowing is described I mean
pretty much I would say it's more like
you squeeze it inside you yak I was
trying to describe swallowing someone
you kind of squeeze it through
cuz it's constant squeeze all the way
through in and out and you sort of you
sort of jerk the life juice out of it
while you're squeezing it inside you I
love jerking the life juice out of it
that's like my favorite part of it okay
are we ready let's go deeper
I can't look outside help help come come
get on the gun maybe and then get off
and see if that fixes it can't look
outside well if you want to do the gun
I'll do the inside no no no no no I'm
good I'm good I'm good I'm good in here
I probably should be looking at the the
inside maybe it's just cuz this ship
only two people maybe one can't look
outside here so it's all suffer that's
fine I got this what is that that seems
bad
what does it describe it to me you got
to describe every water iceberg under
water ice for an iceberg I'm gonna shoot
the [ __ ] out of it and see if an alien
comes or nearly Oh
everyone calm the [ __ ] down I'm not
panicking at all I'm good look out Mork
did you see that yeah hey [ __ ] off the
game keeps telling me to press Q to look
outside those like caps just maybe [ __ ]
oh no I mean the button lights up when I
press it so it's it's responding but
it's just not doing it so that's fine
Oh repair I'll see to it that you guys
get repaired whatever you guys are share
well I said I'm dead damage not today
not today not today we're not hey when
I'm actually paying attention full time
to the ship bye
I'm really quick on these repair yeah no
you're very good when you pay attention
yeah and the ship is like smaller so
it's easier to get to the right things
at the right time I bet it looks really
cool out there you guys really got to be
descriptive about this
it looks amazing it's all out of this
well what can you move away from it a
little bit please there we go go on for
that oh yeah yeah I see it in my bunk
nice you gotta get out get out
get out get out go to bed there we go
hello starfish I got a bed for a minute
Berger's chasing us didn't know that was
a thing well taking guns real quick just
to look it's directly below us oh oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] okay I I press the wrong
button thing going for the thing okay
I'll come back I'll come are you trade
off in three two one go
good work there's a dent somewhere I
don't know where I'll find it I was
gonna keep going deeper that's a good
idea
that's the we need to do mixing fixing
pixel fixing fixing all right Wade you
might be in trouble there's three holes
in your room if you could pop off for
just a second and get back in I'll watch
the gun actually I'll come help you and
we're almost good we're good okay resume
I'm ready I'm ready I'm so ready own it
boys we're doing it doing it we're doing
we're going up another little mini
iceberg we ate landlubbers here like the
music mm-hmm it's very underwater
exploration yeah I bet it's good it
sounds real good in here the music I can
hear it too
also I can hear the music do you not
have music because you're inside because
that doesn't make sense I don't know I
turned it down there I'll crank I'll
crank the tunes I also offered to trade
with you I just want to sit down oh I'm
fine I'm good I'm good by myself it's
good you guys what did this life and
then our gonna proceed to just moan
about it constantly I've got you new
torpedo and your show I'm doing a very
important job I'm not moaning how's it
feel to be treated like I get treated
more what are you talking about you get
treated with respect all the time and
I'm getting treated with respect that's
that's what it is
oh hey I opened the fig and there's
things I see some things out the window
nice bird the funny thing is like I can
actually see out the windows pretty
clearly that's a lot of noises it's all
squid squid squid I'm gonna focus the
squid fixing fixing fixing fixing out
[ __ ] that hurts
our turn guys guess what no no no you're
good you're good
no I'm actually I'm actually having a
blast here this is intense once once the
action starts and I got a repair things
it's actually pretty cool space so hard
now I've got the music now the music's
pumping I hear the music oh yeah now you
go fires as fast as it can work we're
gonna get sucked are you ready to get
sucked on no why squid up squid up squid
up get in the cave get in the cave
getting the cave okay okay I have no
reason to believe it's bad okay okay
looking out cave looks clear guys I'm
sleeping it's just heaven [ __ ] yeah baby
oh that's it
no here up here at the rocks shred
shrimp and baby crab Marx is going for
the loot he don't give a [ __ ] yeah you
know me oh [ __ ] oh hey careful there's a
named enemy up there just for the record
think there's a strip yep I'll be there
hang on I'm coming what are you out
alright clams dead well backpack go
ahead go ahead pop you got it you got it
Bob I believe in your three health I
guess maybe I should go sleep uh yeah no
sleep no sleep no sleep a pearl up here
got some months I'll just be real
passive with this guy alright but if you
get hurt again just run away hey you
guys get some good shot
if you get an extra thing I can carry an
extra skate right by these enemies to go
for the treasure chest
Oh bark did it last time didn't I beat
every enemy on the way there I didn't
skip any the enemy there what's in the
chest No
it was his gold oh really yeah you guys
want to see some I got a we can barrel
earlier that's nice
hey what's up it was hey Bob how's it
going this is how people move yeah I've
seen it all right there's a mr. more
[ __ ] up here is there oh really
yeah there's a breakable wall I don't
believe you oh whoa oh I'm in the
enemies
I've got the name one here oh [ __ ] you
guys found a different way all your Park
cord I sure did out to health 12-12-12
I'm going I'm going
ah good bet it's good very comfortable
very comfy very calm Plus lots of plush
happening
hey has everybody watching followed Bob
and wait on their twitch channels yeah
because if you haven't [ __ ] you yeah I'm
so sad don't power up yet him sleeping
power up market powering up I'm power up
or powered you lazy bastard yeah what
are you doing in bed hey I can look
outside now see how cool it is out here
no I didn't but now I do
well there's where the Ice Bowl that
doesn't like ice cave maybe we don't go
in that one else bad that's bad yeah all
right let's go I'm gonna give you a
stroke say no for now that was a big hit
where is it go in the same direction
wait get a little speed get us away whoa
whoa oh yeah we need we need to take
care of these guys quick cuz we are
taking a lot of pain oh [ __ ] another one
oh yeah guard that one art oh you've got
something inside you inside you Bob
inside me yeah hey there's the pedo use
the pedo or use the torpedo not the pedo
no JEP alright we're safe mark we're
safe okay fixing this league here
and oh we cannot take that much damage
nice burn mama pants all right check it
out this cave I think it might be a
civilization undersea civilization do
not attack them this time know who you
telling we telling way up here up here
up here we can't afford any of this I'm
just gonna go hang out on the [ __ ] yeah
it looks like we got nothing we can get
here this is a good place to stop
yeah nice power to the engines we need
to go deeper boys Wow he said the thing
he said the thing Bobby said the thing
I'm Chris placeholder okay I'm gonna be
I'm gonna be on torpedo duty so feel
free to be liberal with the torpedoes
get reloaded I've only got so much boost
we're about to start taking damage
there's the first hit need to repair
that nice nice nice nice nice the first
boss and we had a pretty decent piloted
if I say so myself all right
pilot seems like kind of a dick okay
well I tried to give us all three
compliments and that was okay you're the
one who ate your food while we are
streaming how about that oh that does
not make me take my hand off the
keyboard for more than like 10 seconds
at a time I only took my hand off the
keyboard for a few minutes what then
what is happening
oh they - what nom nom
mom why are you guys eating it I'm just
staring off into oblivion
can I not eat I got an extra health
point oh [ __ ] me too
we did yeah now you me and Wade are at
11 out of 11
oh it's lights lights lights lights
incoming we need okay we got one less
shield we've got lights though sorry
Connor are we only on one we're on one
gun we got one on everything right now
so shields are gonna be low but I'm
gonna be watching for repairs I'm giving
them the D we're going deep we're going
we are heroes watch out there to grab me
that's a grabbing 18:06 on the wall
there you see the little thing I saw it
it's gonna stay away from that he [ __ ]
on us he does [ __ ] all that rust that is
a truth alright we're gonna keep going
deeper yeah that's what we do that's how
we do here we go deep we go real do you
need to do it we're gonna go do we give
deeper we go deep dude we give so deep
you know how deep I don't know how
comfortable I am with that dude round
Christmas I give deep you're loaded
we're about 600 okay oh it's up here
you're all right mark yeah we're good
we're good we're good
and last hole is good or should be no
where's there's one more somewhere just
just hover for a second we have a little
Narwhal thing Oh
our board at Florida for deported
careful I didn't see him yet but I live
down here that's a big guy oh you got
sick [ __ ]
that's gonna be annoying you guys good
we're still killing him is real you
doesn't do much all right
just really just makes me seasick all
right all right well I'll try to clean
up your [ __ ] for you we are such a good
team guys I just wanted to say how close
I fall to you guys you're so deep right
now when you're looking outside the
windows at the ship outside I am right
up in your business giving you like
affirm Tory hugs I appreciate that
hug did you feel that way I felt that
can you do it again oh oh I hug Bob and
I got sick you [ __ ] my [ __ ] bullets
you take to kill [ __ ] I bet
we're gonna get a medkit in this game I
bet I bet all right well I have a
backpack so I can be the the med boy got
like a snail or subscribe don't you guys
[ __ ] on me yeah I don't think you can
avoid it man
I'll [ __ ] this snail I'm gonna get you
from behind it good work I'm gonna make
sure it stays dead what am i dying of
right now what is happening no need to
go taking now there's like three snails
in this I think keep spawning what the
hell it's like moore's infinite snails I
don't know I'm gonna go take a nap you
go one come on a healthy boy or clam
rather that's yes crab slam and Sam Raab
suck it in there I'm calming boys oh
hello you didn't get very much further
yeah we did
Cameron the nimble's dead I'm gonna go
nap real quick I don't really need it
but stay healthy guys so healthy in the
ceiling I don't see
do you wanna know drugs man wait what
was in that same buddy Jessop backpack
here get this backpack someone get that
yeah oh [ __ ] I can't hit that hey what's
up Oh God
snaily yeah oh you can hit it from right
here and not be in its areas Wow
mark I think you're in his areas I was
in his areas yes take that [ __ ] oh it's
a trap
drop all your [ __ ] out ok I'm at 3 I'm
going to heal poor money everywhere
[ __ ] feel free to help me wait that
was what the enemy that's killing me
there was nothing what the hell I'm
having a weird issue did you just run
past me to get that glutton another
watch watch my perspective there was no
enemy snails up there I got the skills
to pay the bills so many bills being
paid here I've killed so many snails you
guys should be so grateful
did you kill all us finds you yes I did
yes I [ __ ] hey what's up snails well I
can't help what you run into I got three
I got the treasure there's nothing else
there it's just some enemies we I don't
think we need to kill them all right and
three two one yeah it's all yours i shat
in it but guys we have 49 torpedoes yeah
alright let me know when you're ready
I'm ready sir Oh give me like always God
lights on
all right okay there we go guys we need
to go deeper all we said the thing oh
[ __ ] alright we have a total of bad
how'd you drive right at it what are you
doing
there was a grabby on the left I had to
dodge I got it I got it Bob's just I got
another one he's the one thing just go
shoot him
Oh another blobby that one's coming man
oh [ __ ] move wait so [ __ ] it was to
[Music]
lobby I'm fighting them off now that I
would finally done with that guy my time
I get back down you let me tend more spa
don't be so pessimistic
we dog [ __ ] we're good no no well I mean
it is you guys are shoulders I would
rather have blobs than things that would
actually kill us God what an ugly piece
of [ __ ] what kind of sea creature is
that is that a real thing no it's real
it's real it's real it looks exactly the
same as it's real picture we're getting
sucked okay oh not a good place to get
sucked Evie you're the bus Amy thank you
Mark load me four pianos
okay loading loading I'm loading a me
got me Wendy's guys okay you're loaded
what is this quality okay you're loaded
yeah it's fine we're good
Paul oh my goodness he got me Wendy's
yes like a stop for some Wendy's where's
this bottle of oh what's that somebody
pick it up yeah I can't because
obviously I need the wrench but oh I'm
gonna die now why what it poisoned me
and I have one health now Jesus well it
did look like a poison it was very
poison oh yeah you did say oh what's
this poison and I was like oh this
poison find out what it is oh god it's
poison this is the power up the
anglerfish is on us yeah I'm gonna be
I'm gonna on the gunner's three two one
power whoa God lights oh okay
fine I don't see the angler maybe you
spawned yeah we're gonna go down just
let us at the boss we're at 2700 feet
sorry faddish oh can we go with that I
think we should try it
alright we're gonna go inside movies Oh
what you doing
Oh what is this it's a civilization who
for all this gold that I have they're
parasites a shell ooh they got something
shot up the guts medkit oh we can afford
it to get it I'll get it
maybe we can both buy one oh we need
more than one I don't think so Oh Oh No
[Music]
oh we just got a boogie out of here just
get to the ship and get out go oh wait
are you in the ship he had mark you're
the only one alive drive the ship away
girl things okay it just clicks I guess
[Music]
god damn it
well that was my bad but I don't
understand what happened I was just
trying to buy the thing and then I
shattered the glass and then they
attacked the [ __ ] out of us
you think you had to talk to the
merchant or something I was just hitting
E oh wait we have we have some gold now
can we buy a medkit from the catalog
it's like a starting kit sure spicy huh
hey hey I feel you're famous Oh does
anyone want to switch I could do
whatever
I'm good with where I was I liked it you
sure yeah I just don't want anyone to
have I mean I feel like the gun is like
with a fun one
no I don't want anyone to have to do
time piloting I don't want the pressure
of like having to aim if you like it
then go for it yeah me either I felt a
lot of pressure with you guys like
waiting you know shoot anything that'd
be fair you weren't shooting anything I
mean you're not wrong Bobby not wrong we
drive on the correct side of the road is
like well Americans invented driving and
then one guy was like Touche Touche
you're right when you're right you're
right I can't I can't look outside yet
we have to get to a cave before I can I
have a privilege shut up and fix it all
right I will
all right a little boss road eople Rico
remember describe it to me I'm ready
there's a water
some green fish out there I can see you
pretty pretty
buh buh doo buh buh buh that's not the
button repair you lying sack of [ __ ] III
appreciate it I feel like you guys
really appreciate Who I am as a parcel
you know the best way to best way to win
this is by following Bob and Wade over
on their twitch channels that's the best
way to do this we did just break ninety
thousand followers almost to a six six
figures over here livin large cuz I have
my dashboard up when I stream so that I
can see what's happening to myself oh
that's the button and you're like god
damn I hope I'm streaming to the right
twitch page yes
if only there were some information
about this on some sort of website stop
stop looks clear if we all die so you're
like a bottle of bottle of Oh what's
happening fuel fuel on your screen yeah
for the booze exclamation point
you picked up oh whoa Carol Carol Carol
Carol Carol
oh god Carol you're so vengeful out
you're dead can you revive me with oh
yeah apparently I can how did you die I
didn't keep track of my health very well
it's just like a health penalty right
yeah you lose one total max health oh
sorry weights are fish meat thank you I
don't I don't see things correctly on my
screen just Oh God fine
what's up being so nimble I like how way
just sit still aren't they hurting you
when you do that
not really no you can attack them from
outside their range by sitting still all
right you're gonna have it oh you can oh
I was here moving and dancing like crazy
I know I was like dodging like an
[ __ ] just sitting there just outside
there what we got 777 go right now god
that means stuff oh don't you do
something you can do some sweet rolls
I'm enjoying watching this don't mind me
Russian striptease nice work on that see
oh Jesus Christ oh oh oh [ __ ] it
released the thing Ron whoa whoa what
would that working on it
whoa what the [ __ ] guys I just found the
radar what Wayne are do it it's a radar
what my Kamini I can see tactical
information I can see farther than you
can see with your eyes we have already
yeah we have a radar what's in that cave
what's it say about the cave it doesn't
say anything about the cave it just says
that there's a cave there and I can see
it from a way far away what okay once we
get outside
if you press Q and then press space you
access the radar oh it's this guy
I should definitely eat that well that
looks fancy Bob freezing munitions
that's good
and nanners they hit space and Q no Q
and then space once once we're out and
we could actually use to outside view
radar would have been so whoa what the
[ __ ] I know right that's amazing yeah
that's pretty cool
holy [ __ ] what uh [ __ ]
you can even see enemies that seems new
wait there's another cave we can go up
and then back around and go to that
other cave we have the down
okay you're right you're right we're
stuck maybe if we
when you're right you're right oh boy
acta coal guide mark where are we going
it's open for the rest of the way down
you've got clear a swordfish incoming
from bottom right what about five
o'clock oh there's a shark at about
three o'clock far off the right star
from North Nemo from two o'clock Oh
[ __ ] sake I'm gonna go out I'm gonna
get on capito loading firing torpedo
loaded thank you we're good on the
outside
yeah there's a chicken octopus a chick -
puss are it's dead it's going to push
the rock because we're problems yeah
yeah I'm going for the guns this just
got a lot more tactical with this we're
using we're using our freezing torpedos
yeah the torpedoes freeze them now yeah
that's all we've got we've got nothing
else yeah something coming off it's on
let me here we go I'm fighting it it's
up in the pilot cabin I need to sleep
after that that did a lot of damage
chill it this got crazy more tactical
holthusen yeah I really did yeah
alright we have got it's alright it's
already connected there's a cave
directly below us though or some kind of
object it might be one of the it might
be like that Roman Colosseum looking
thing down to the seven o'clock from
where we are right now this is the place
where I got it no this is a place where
you guys killed yeah alright so this
time I'm not gonna do a thing put my can
I put my wrench away now I don't have a
backpack hello I'm gonna not do anything
because we probably can't buy anything
anyway we've got enough gold through
this one we could afford this stuff yeah
all the rivet guns really dope is that a
really great thing what does what do is
this
no God ship go ahead we can't outrun
they get on the ship with us yeah but
I'm gonna know get in the ship I'm an
eternal and how power I'm gonna power
are you in we're going yeah go there on
the drive tractor only madam only one of
them only one of them only one of them
[ __ ] he's tough ah [ __ ] me he's
gonna kill me now I killed me [ __ ]
I was holding e Jesus Christ oh [ __ ] who
is that what is this what a satellite
man just boarded our ship and gave us
stuff and killed me what the [ __ ] oh my
god how do you interact with those
things with now [ __ ] doing that I
don't know I literally was holding me
and trying to look at what the thing was
do I have enough to buy the medkit ooh
or the gun I could buy the gun or the
med kit does anyone have enough to buy
anything
we all have same amount of gold I think
yeah so mark you're gonna be the only
one who could fix yeah I'll be fine with
that
alright one more time guys we got this
we got that time it's gonna not even
when we go to a place where it's like
that I'm gonna knock it off the boat and
just [ __ ] it
cuz I've done that twice now and that
just ruins it for everyone I'm gonna boy
let's do it I like doing the callouts
now that's of a new thing I can't do it
initially because for some reason I
can't see around for some reason that's
no no it's whatever choose an item a gun
hey guys I have a gun now alright cool
bang bang done guns you guys like my bag
yes
hate me with their daddy I'm afraid too
right now cuz if I use it now I'll be
pissed
no it doesn't go away it you just hit
people with it and it heals them we've
had it once before it's like unlimited
use I don't know can you heal yourself I
forget I don't think so can't right you
need to try not to take damage and you
need to stand behind me and I'll make a
bang bang and you make a heal to heal
operation to protect your captain all
right ready engine on going on what
that's a mission it's the ice world hey
I can see outside all right cool yeah
you ready oh yeah oh all right only one
yeah do six o'clock only one path it's
very wide open to the right there's
nothing right nothing to the right
straight shot down opens up a little bit
no distinguishing features the music is
so hopeful this time it really is it
knows that we have good stuff both sides
left and right pull there's another
iceberg on the left no there's a cave on
the left side it's one of the curlicue
she'll always write left or down down
through the pull there's a cave let's
get sucked boys it's just gonna be
hermit hermit men I'm not sure I've got
the gun oh it is hermit man I love her
man give us your [ __ ] trash for us
oh good that's worthy that's a complete
gun upgrade Spreadshirt yeah what's this
other thing someone else get this other
thing I don't want to upgrade already
active what is that oh that's an EMP
upgrade maybe oh that's right this has
an upgraded EMP oh yeah hey the gun
looks cool yeah is the shotgun like the
the gun bullet gun or though yeah I
think I think it's the I think it's the
unlimited ammo what the [ __ ] yeah all
right
engines on
guns on shields up all right we're good
to go all the gun is upgraded oh my god
that's nuts
it was a good upgrade for the ship I
thought that was enough grid freely
there's an enemy you probably can see it
dude all right you're clear there's an
enemy three o'clock behind that Ridge
coming down now four o'clock so [ __ ]
dead he's over to the right he ran away
to the right because he knows I've got
the shotgun and he's [ __ ] dead all
right
just that iceberg no enemies spotted
[ __ ] that iceberg [ __ ] you iceberg
because we're all part of the same ship
man
cohesive unit on a fish seven o'clock
eight o'clock coming in you probably saw
before I even call it alright Orca five
five four three almost 3 o'clock good
call good call
it pushes him away too it's only right
there's nothing to the left
you couldn't even swim over to us I feel
bad honestly I don't feel bad at all
time traveller time traveller what is
that hey hey yeah what are you doing
wait you just pooped a guy out what oh
oh god oh god oh god what the [ __ ] is
that I murdered him I murdered him dick
oh he gave me some disease you Wow [ __ ]
I've got space AIDS
oh god I'm good yeah you healed me you
heal me wait wait wait I'm dying heal me
hit me one more time hit me one more
time thank God we have the goddamn medic
Jesus
you wanted me to get to show off that
sweet medkit and it's true you got to
eat your toy I'm traveling just had our
bags he acted like a dick but it was
like it was benefit good dick I love
good dick go there's an iceberg there's
nothing all right
only one way I can town straight down
only one way to [ __ ] just they both
go same place go left on it I like this
I like this penguin penguin penguin four
key one good coming in I'm gonna focus
penguin nice I'm gonna focus both of
them okay penguin is on board
he's inside he's inside where's yet he's
named his finger oh he killed me he's
very tough got him okay I think you're a
leak up here I'm reviving mark yeah we
can go fix it yeah I'm gonna I'm just
gonna go fix it anyway I'm at nine yeah
I'm good I'm I've raised with full
health apparently yeah that guy was
tough
hold down below but it looks like
there's a cave there as well I believe
that's a cave not harm percent sure oh
that might be a boss cave we can check
it out but I've got the gun now I'll
peek first okay wait oh yeah oh yeah oh
it's a lair gardial oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] he grabbed me from inside what the
[ __ ] he grabbed we gotta go oh god is he
gonna let me go is he ever gonna let me
go I don't think he's gonna yes he let
me go with the skinny he got me somehow
okay waiting you like reach the door
[ __ ] Brad yeah you did
park fix the holes be ready to go
high-five how'd you get ahead get in let
me know when you're in I'm dead [ __ ]
what all right hanging we're gonna have
to fight this I'm gonna fight him okay
you get your D half he's already half
he just missed me I'm gonna fix this
ship hold just because
that's a problem you get out of his grip
he just lets you go I think I made you
out god damn it he's punching holes in
there are you okay out there Bob I've on
he hasn't touched me yet okay I'm trying
to fix this one last hole oh [ __ ] he
grabbed me gasps [ __ ] are you dead no I
might be it just depends what spell Oh a
rock hit me I'm dead okay marking hell
what that guy's so bad
holy [ __ ] and we even almost got it yeah
Bobby Robert no it hasn't
I'm gonna choose to believe you I can't
see you but see his hell's going down
he's almost he's almost dead I'm in kind
of a spot where he can't hit me and I
just have to kill us little drones
before they get me got this Bob Bob we
didn't you holy [ __ ] blue sky we're
gonna do this uh [ __ ] you no don't throw
me don't throw me bro oh you're so close
there we go there we go I got the trail
Bob Bob you got him you got him Bob
throw me bro
don't drop me bro you gotta call me bro
yes oh that's still a drone alright hang
on I gotta revive you guys holy [ __ ] I
get market morning at me oh that's
that's wait but it's okay oh sorry I
couldn't get the other one
there we go holy [ __ ] get [ __ ]
alright what what is that what is that
corrosive munitions [ __ ] yeah do we have
any backpacks no no no backpacks come on
uh let's explore together would yeah
I'll be here I'll be your ear fight day
you need health i'm phileo all right I'm
coming out whoa alright I don't know
oopsies
oh this oh yeah I don't think there's
anything up there and that was not
[ __ ] that was not worth that [ __ ]
that dude okay well issues might be good
with that there's a gun there's a better
gun up here hang on I'm gonna upgrade my
gun we're just like there's up here is
like
oh I don't know if that's better it
looks cool
oh yeah the sugar does a lot of damage
mmm I'm gonna go with that and see since
I have the gun anyway
cool yeah I hope the pickaxe isn't
something that can also repair you want
to try it are they're awful I repaired
fully I don't want to risk it just
because I wish we had a backpack that
have been nice
oh well anyway you guys anybody need
help marketing to heal I'm good I'm good
if you hit tabloid you can see our
Health's all marks you down to max of
eight I done yeah fine hopefully we get
the food thing at some point and we get
a someone get some more Health's yeah
all right you guys ready yeah I can do I
was you didn't get a health boost Bob
for killing the boss yeah it seems like
I thought we got one last or was it the
depth that gave us a bonus it was just
getting past the first boss like outside
of this I don't know if that was worth
it but that was very fun that was cool
all right looks clear I got grabbed out
of the ship and me dude yeah is that a
cave do to the right there might be a
cave three o'clock all right can we risk
this anywhere near them I'm gonna sting
yeah I'm gonna stand with my gun next to
the ship and do nothing our way do you
have a medicine thing I'd that probably
wouldn't hurt anything right don't risk
it everybody click your mouse I'm not
gonna click [ __ ] okay here's the stuff
oh really gold I have nine mil yeah
[Music]
didn't do anything I'm on the boat thank
God alright ready yeah it wasn't me for
once we survived that encounter the
deadly I just see on the radar I can see
the giblets on the radar so it's just I
like the way they they eviscerate
anytime I shoot them the tiny starfish
explodes just as big as one of the
[ __ ] giant orcas this might be the
boss chamber looks pretty open below oh
I'm [ __ ] ready give it to me alright
come here [ __ ] where you at Huntress
[ __ ] better than the torpedo is this
like a really rare thing to get I feel
like this gun is ridiculous it was like
1500 at the gold places so it must be
pretty hard to get yeah what was even
better than that and there's gotta be
must be really like that I'm just like
the murder guy if this was Firefly I
would be Shane right now oh dude yeah I
would be that other character who drives
I'd be the lady I'd be that lady
everyone knows that I'm disappointed in
you do I get to all right we're in some
bonus boner cast time your damage repair
mine repair went up alright I have a
question does this save no I don't think
so
okay I I can go for another ten minutes
all right give it lights lights Raj yes
incoming six o'clock seven o'clock which
way do I want to go another content five
o'clock keep going straight down we've
got a cave at five o'clock another
contact five o'clock
the caves are here cave is five o'clock
yes creepy dude not this time no go away
wait to me off [ __ ] off what you're
[ __ ] invincible no you're not oh my
god guys my damage is this is a real
cave yeah just well just filled me with
you my god having heels is zone whoa
back up back up back up back up
all right yeah you use just standby just
stand behind me a little [ __ ] out of
them I'm just gonna keep swinging my uh
my meds I'll kill the corpses I'll kill
the corpses
no problemo boys all right I'm getting
low on mana you have mana no okay that's
like what the [ __ ] don't worry big dick
Bob's on the case thank you big dick Bob
you're our hero big dick Bob I'm really
glad that we've got your big dick energy
hey I shot this dirt and some gold came
out
what the [ __ ] okay back the [ __ ] up them
that thing holy [ __ ] is it dead yeah I
guess Jesus Christ what's in the thing
bro babies we're also invested in the
teamwork now we were like you take no
you open all the way oh it's so nice
there's one more snail in here but
that's it I think it was guarding
nothing you feel nice and heal oh wait
we're coming
I forgot how to jump don't worry big
dick Bob's here thank you big dick Bob
big deep ball you need a theme song oh I
don't think this is anything I'm healed
up
yeah I'm fine baby it's [ __ ] amazing
yeah that gun is [ __ ] amazing
dude Bobby you so good our navigation is
the radar Oh dead end Wade go left
instead of right whoa attacking whoa
whoa whoa what's that yeah I got it it's
good are there any more out of there
anymore yeah there's one more hole so
there must be a hole in my room there's
a hole in my room well there's a
tentacle down here all right you got
tentacles dead there's a hole done oh
man my hair is much faster it's off of
us oh this is so much better being able
to repair this good oh yeah keep going
I'll focus okay take care of the
bullfight octopus [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I gotta
hold my room mark I'm gonna have and
clear the downstairs I'll be there in
just two seconds here we go dad oh [ __ ]
you were dead I didn't realize my help
is going down coming for ya I'm coming
I'm coming forward don't worry where's
one hole up here I know it's it's full
of a tentacle first we're hitting
something bad I think I'm
shooting the squid and the anglerfish
there's an anglerfish on us that's a big
hole all right we're good obsessive get
the whole smark on there we're [ __ ]
huge whole thing reporting everywhere
there are a couple holes in the ladder
space yeah yeah okay we're good Wolfie
Wolfie thank you for the color
anglerfish outside I should be able to
fight them off on my own oh [ __ ] we got
to anglerfish yeah yeah just keep go go
make some space somewhere give good mark
yeah we're good we're good we're good
we're gonna [ __ ] there's one more I
don't know where it is oh it's in your
room wait you might be drowning it was
behind you you're good you're good with
normal [ __ ] oh my god yeah I don't know
that wood can you get on the radar mark
I think the radar radar we're clear
there's a path down to the bottom left
about 7:30 keep going straight the way
you're going you're headed towards
contacts nine o'clock small oh go down
I'll fight it off
whoa there's well anglers do not appear
on the radar just FYI squits down went
down I'm gonna give you extra gun real
quick good Paul oh nice oh my god it
shoots so fast are you [ __ ] me
it shoots so fast another angler on the
right we guys we got parasites on board
I got I got hit pretty bad coming coming
they're dead
down here I'm warned of the cave go more
yeah we need heal yeah we dare say
there's a hole in my room I'm diseased I
don't think I can fix myself maybe if
there's an item in this cave we can
trade it out slowly are you dying I
don't I'm just at seven health I don't
know oh I can't heal though I think this
whatever this disease is keeps me from
being able to heal all right I got bad
news guys I gotta go
no I'm so sorry I would like nothing
more than to keep going with this but I
really if I don't leave now I'll never
make it
have them meet you halfway
[Laughter]
all right but you guys can keep going
without me right no we need all right I
wish I could I really wish I could but I
cannot this is something good run but I
think if we play it again we'll have
just as good run cuz now we know right
no no no all right thank you guys so
much I'm out here take care see you man
[Music]